hey youtubers is Charlie this is going
to be my West world finale video it was
totally crazy they answered most of the
biggest theories there are a couple
teasers for season two so I'll explain
what's going on with season two just
careful for spoilers if you haven't seen
the episode yet I'm going to start a
Westworld giveaway it's just for an HBO
now subscription all you have to do to
enter is be a subscriber and leave a
comment on this video make sure you
click that Bell and enable alerts so
that you don't miss out on anything so
what's going on there's so much to talk
about season two first one there are ten
episodes Ed Harris has been confirmed to
be coming back so I'll explain the twist
with his character at the end but he
said that he doesn't think that they're
going to start filming till next June or
July depending on how long it takes to
film it could premiere at the beginning
of 2018 or during the summer or even
during this time but that means that
there will not be new Westworld episodes
next year which is a bummer but I felt
like the series actually stuck the
landing pretty well like it kind of
found its legs it had a few production
problems behind the scenes they had to
halt production for a little while to
finish the last couple of scripts and
aside from all the actors playing
characters that were still alive in the
final moments of the episode they
haven't really confirmed who's coming
back like they haven't said whether or
not Anthony Hopkins is going to play a
role but think about it this way you
know number two is Ford still alive what
was that mystery body that Ford was
fabricating in the underground lab was
that a body for himself is he going to
turn himself into another Bernard the
problem with that is that it would kind
of undercut his death at the end of the
episode so it seems like he's largely
gone but because of the way the hosts
have access to all their memories
simultaneously you can still bring the
Ford character back it's just it'll be a
previous version of him so in present
day Ford is probably dead but that
doesn't mean that you've seen the last
of Anthony Hopkins on the show but I
don't think that he's going to come back
as a host but speaking of which number
three what was the red wedding all about
like are they gonna make Game of Thrones
world George are Martin actually did say
that it would be really cool to have a
game of Thrones world inside the world
of the show which you know just sounds
amazing
the thing
at the red wedding is that Ford was
probably trying to neutralize the board
like he was probably trying to kill
Charlotte the man in black
anybody that would seek to harm the host
and stop them from becoming the people
that he wanted them to try and become so
what does that mean about the man in
black
we know he survived somehow even though
he seemed really happy when he got shot
with the shotgun in the arm so he
probably found a way to escape in those
final moments but he is going to do
everything he can to protect the park
now because he got what he wanted he
wanted hosts that could fight back he
wanted Westworld to truly be real for
the consequences to be final in other
the handful of sentient hosts have
achieved consciousness again he's gotten
that so he is probably the happiest
person at the end of this episode
despite the fact that they're out for
his blood like they're trying to kill
him right now
and he's smiling with his big
shit-eating grin on his face but the
whole thing with charlotte she was
saying that she doesn't care what
happens inside the park as long as they
dumb it down so the man in black was on
board with that for a little while like
he didn't care about Ford but now he's
probably going to backtrack on that and
just do everything he can to make sure
the sentient host there's like a small
population of sentient hosts just
continue to exist but number four let's
talk about the maze it was this big red
herring for the entire season the maze
is really just the process by which
Dolores and the other sentient hosts
bootstrap their own consciousness as
Ford said the great gift doesn't come
from a higher power it comes from within
that was what the Michelangelo's
painting was all about like you look at
this image here and then you realize
that there's the human brain hidden here
so the person speaking to Dolores
guiding her back to this place - like
where this little tin with the maze was
each time is actually herself her
memories from the first time she
achieved consciousness this isn't the
first time that she's become sentient
like she achieves that goal then his
Ford and Barnard have said they've
rolled them back unless they go insane
and then they stick them down here so
all the hosts that were standing down
here
all the naked hoes those were the ones
that achieve sentience and went insane
like in the past 35 years ago when
Arnold is explaining the maze to Dolores
like don't worry Dolores you'll get it
you'll understand he's talking about how
like as they slowly make their way to
the center of the maze they can go
spiraling out and go crazy these hosts
here like the Abernathy host went insane
when they achieve consciousness
Dolores on the other side of that did
not like she was able to handle it but
she still got rolled back so the only
thing that really made me upset about
this big reveal is that the man in black
just did not figure it out he was way
thicker than I thought that he would be
like he's shaking Dolores asking for a
Wyatt and there's no light bulb in his
head he doesn't realize that Dolores is
really Wyatt but number five what's
going to happen to Dolores now she just
killed a whole bunch of people the park
is on lockdown so it seems like the
people in the control room that would be
able to record what's happening don't
have access to that so they don't know
that all these people are getting
slaughtered right here so season two is
just a bunch of these conscious hosts
just trying to make decisions for it had
that big speech about the choices that
they would have to make the people that
they would choose to be like they have
to figure out as a group what they're
going to do now that they have their own
free will
which speaks to maybe you know number
six whydid Maeve get off the train and
who had rewritten her program to cause
her to try and leave the part like she
thought that she was breaking her loop
but then Bernard found out that she was
really just following a new narrative
that somebody had secretly written for
her without a name on it so what I think
was going on is that Ford rewrote her
narrative and caused her to try and
break her loop so that she would create
a distraction that would allow his red
wedding narrative to play out but Maeve
armistice and Hector all did achieve
sentence they were part of the sentient
hosts so I would expect them to come
back sentient next season armistice had
that great post credit scene they just
wanted to let you know that she was
still alive and was still going to go on
a killing spree
so armistice had one of the most fun
performances from the episode she was
one of the MVPs
just that smile on her face like she was
just having so much fun
so next big question the samurai world
what is up with Kurosawa world so if you
guys don't know there was the
Shakespeare line these violent delights
have violent ends there were a lot of
people speaking Shakespeare during the
season so when mabe was like what is all
this what are all these samurai and
Felix says it's complicated it's just
them teasing that there's a whole other
Park based on Eastern culture that's
what the samurai were all about it's not
part of West world it's like a whole
different other place so the idea is
that we'll start seeing multiple parts
like the sequel to the original West
world movie was called future world it
was about a completely different type of
part so they'll just be this Kurosawa
Park so just to bring it back around to
Shakespeare the thing about Kurosawa is
that he made some amazing samurai films
but they were all adaptations of
Shakespeare plays so if you really
thought it was freaky and awesome when
people like Abernathy in that first
episode we're speaking Shakespeare that
creepy way we might get a whole bunch of
samurais speaking Shakespeare in season
2 but number 8
why did Maeve get off the train so that
was all happening with the voiceover
from Ford doing the speech about the
choices that they would have to make the
people they would choose to become lies
that told a deeper truth so the thing
about her daughter is that she's not
really her daughter because they're
artificial she was created and they just
wrote a story where she was her daughter
but the Michelangelo painting deeper
meaning for Maeve was that her daughter
really meant something to her she had
this emotional bond to her so she was
choosing her daughter over her freedom
so she will probably retain her
sentience and just go back and try to
find her daughter now but number 9 what
happened to Logan in the past William
man in black confirmed who stuck him on
the horse naked with the feather at the
edge of the park and just set him off
running so they played it really
ambiguously like did he die did they
find him eventually
and his
father gave William controlled the
company because they thought that Logan
was so crazy because they found him
naked on a horse riding at the edge of
the park the whole speech that William
had at the end was your father will
probably want someone more stable to run
the company so what that probably
implies is that they eventually did find
Logan but they thought he was totally
crazy ranting about all the crazy stuff
that William did no one believed him so
they just kind of tucked him away in an
office at the dell o--'s corporation
never to be heard from again but the
woman that William was getting ready to
marry was Logan's sister so Logan
probably told her she probably believed
him
so a couple of episodes ago when the man
in black said his whole life his wife
was afraid of him that's probably why
she probably believed about all the
crazy stuff that Logan said that he did
while they were inside the park but
number 10 the photograph so a lot of you
detected this earlier the photograph in
the past like the 30 year ago William
young William dropped it as he was
dragging Logan around that was later
found by Abernathy who stared at it and
achieved sentience went insane and set
off the events at the end of that first
episode so went away William the man in
black kind of helps set this all off but
the way they explain it is is that the
hosts achieve sentience all the time and
they just roll them back so this has
been happening for a long time it's just
that Ford had been building towards a
moment where he could make it stick so
the board still had a lot of control
over him so that's probably why he
couldn't let this happen before now like
he explains in the past he had the
argument with Arnold he didn't believe
that the host could be sentient but then
after Arnold's death he changed his mind
so started the long process of trying to
help the host become the people that
Arnold thought that they could
eventually become so there was a lot of
Ford language in the episode that made
it sound like they would eventually get
out of the park he wasn't you know if
you ever hope to get outside of this
place do you know the person that you
have to become so what he meant by that
is that she'll have to achieve
consciousness and not go crazy like
she'll have to learn to be able to
exists with humans even though they are
going to inherit the earth eventually so
even though we didn't see Maeve get
outside of the park I do think that
eventually in one of these future
seasons they have like five seasons
planned we'll see a host outside in the
real world in what this is all implying
is that by the series finale like
whatever the final season is the final
episode the host will all break free and
inherit the earth
like they'll all be roaming around like
Cylons so if you really wanted to you
could think about this is like a
Battlestar prequel like all the Cylons
are slowly gaining sentience now they're
choosing what to do season two will be
them deciding what they're going to do
with their consciousness but hopefully a
whole lot of samurai world on there so
let me know in the comments do you think
that we are going to see way more
samurai world in season two and leave a
like if you want to see you know
bringing it back around to red wedding
Lannisters Game of Thrones leave a like
if you want to see Charles dance Tywin
Lannister become a member of the Delos
board
we haven't met all the board members but
a lot of them were there so they're
going to have to replace a lot of them
so I would just love to see someone as
evil looking as Tywin Lannister in a
three-piece suit just sitting there
talking with the man in black that would
just be so awesome but what's going to
happen next is is there's a big
transformers trailer that's kind of Game
of Thrones II that'll be dropping later
today I'll be doing a video up at that
then I'll do a Walking Dead finale
trailer video and then I'll do a
Westworld season two predictions video
so that should be the video order but
I'll post updates as I post new videos
while you guys wait for that to post
make sure you click here and watch last
night's episode of The Walking Dead and
you can click here for my Westworld
playlist with all the videos thank you
so much for watching everybody the Thai
pop I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]